-It strikes me that, you know,
from what I know about you
it strikes me
that you believe --
you're someone who thrives
in that situation
where you can get
local with people.
You can be in, you know,
bars or restaurants
talking to them
in the places they live.
As you prepare for
these debates, especially ones
where it will be you
and nine other people onstage,
and, you know, short answers
is it frustrating to then
take that same message that,
given the luxury of a little bit
more time with people,
you feel like gets across
versus what you'll be up
against next week?
-Short answer is yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a very different
experience to try to package
a really complex policy issu
and reflect what you've learne
from everyone that you've
listened to in America
into 60 seconds
and then to attempt to do that
while nine other people ar
talking over you simultaneously.
And yet that's what
we've got to do.
That's where we are right now.
And my task is to come through
as strong and clear as possibl
to define this
as a moment of truth.
You've got somebody holding mass
rallies saying "send them back,"
four members of Congress
who happen to be women of color.
Someone who is locking up kids
in cages.
Someone who has the deaths o
six children who are in our care
in custody on the U.S./Mexic
border on his hands,
on our conscience.
We got to stand up
to be counted right now.
And I want to make sure
that we come through
and this marks the best period
going forward
for the United States
of America,
that we stood up
to this challenge.
We stood up to this bully
and we revealed ourselves
to be an ambitious,
aspirational people,
defined not by fear but by
our courage and our confidence
and the resolve that we show
in order to accomplish
these ambitious goals.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think one perspective you
have that's really unique is
obviously, you know,
you're from El Paso.
It's a border town.
And can you speak to
what we might all be getting
wrong about the border?
Not just with how Republican
have treated the situation there
but how Democrats have as well
-Yeah.
So, El Paso, Texas, my hometown,
is connected with Ciudad Juárez,
and they form the largest
binational community
in the hemisphere.
There's 3 million of us
who are joined, not separated,
by the Rio Grande river,
speaking two languages,
Coming from these two countrie
that form something greate
than the sum of the people
or the parts involved.
And El Paso is one of, if no
the safest cities in America
not despite, but because
it's a city of immigrants
and asylum seekers and refugees.
So what so many people
get wrong right now
is thinking that
Mexico or Mexicans
or immigrants are a threat
Their very presence makes us
stronger and safer
and more secure.
And so if immigration
is a problem,
it is the best possible proble
this country could have.
It's time that we rewrite
our immigration laws
in our own image.
Never again cage a child.
Reunite those families
who've been separated.
Free every single dreamer
from any fear of deportation
And this becomes a stronger,
better, more successful countr
for it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Now, you know what's gonn
happen, though.
Now that you did that,
someone else is gonna use it
at the debate before you.
[ Laughter ]
-Gave it away.
-I do want to ask, obviously
it's a crowded field.
I do think it's very early
and certainly historically
what we see in polling now
is not borne out
as the results of
any presidential election.
We're a ways out.
But I think
some people have asked --
you're obviously this incredibly
talented candidate.
Certainly those in
the Democratic Party said,
"Look, you're
a great Congressman.
You came really close.
Maybe the best use of you isn'
here with everybody else
because all
these talented people
who are now putting
their attention,
and obviously only one of them
can get a shot at this."
How do you -- Do you ever have
doubts and think,
"Oh, maybe this was
the wrong thing for me
to aim for right now"?
-No, I never think that.
I'm doing what I feel is
the most important way for m
to contribute to
this country's success
because I don't think that
any one person
is gonna defeat Donald Trump
or bring this divided countr
together again.
I think it's really
gonna take a movement,
and a movement that doesn't care
if you live in a big city
or a small town,
if you're an independent,
a Democrat, or Republican.
A movement of all of us.
And more than 100,000 people
have signed up
to join this campaign,
to volunteer or knock on doors
Hundreds of thousands have
donated 5 or 10 or 15 bucks.
We have the greatest volunteer
in the country
working their hearts out
right now.
And they all know that
this is a marathon
and there's gonna be highs
There's gonna be lows.
But through that,
we must persist,
and it's the only way that we're
gonna be successful
and secure that nomination
defeat Donald Trump,
and then meet the ambitions of
this country
and see these
great priorities through
once we're in office in 2021
-Alright. Well, thanks so much
for making the time for us
-Thank you, yeah.
Appreciate it, Seth.
-Stay hydrated out there.
Beto O'Rourke, everybody.